[Music]
i know who this guy
is good for me this is from the comics
this is old santa it's not that's a
santy that's bk
holy crap wait if he's in this that
means
you can bring it there's a lot of people
here
he called him it's definitely him that's
so cool this is gonna be doctor
everybody
oh
i love it
so awesome welcome back to new rock
stars the book of boba fett just threw a
hut heavy bone to those of us here at
wookie leaks by leaking an actual wookie
and not just any wookie a big boy by the
name of black kirsantin a character with
a rich history with boba fett with darth
vader with obi-wan kenobi several others
teasing how this boba fett series will
likely now tie into the rest of star
wars canon
what
we're working on
we're working here
what the this is wookie leaks new
rockstars book of boba fett after show
and our weekly reaction to the latest in
star wars i'm eric voss my easter egg
breakdown of this episode it's coming
tomorrow but right now i'm here with
tommy bechtol tommy we've got wookies on
wikileaks that's right finally wookie's
on wikileaks we got racks on racks on
racks and i gotta say crack open the
tours light today because we're talking
about twins
and twins
i wish it wasn't 9 00 am otherwise i
would start drinking yeah who's kidding
i've been drinking since 7am
[Laughter]
i've never stopped uh just around the
clock more on that later
more on that later
so let's break down what happened here
in episode two the tribes of tatooine
boba and finnick interrogate that
nightwind assassin
talking about some knives
i think that was like the name of a ship
at some point but this as a an assassin
organization might be a new thing to
star wars correct me if i'm wrong you
guys always do a good job of that uh but
they're able to get him to squeal with
that old empty rancor pit trick just the
idea of a rancor is enough to make a guy
forget his vows oh my god
that was cr i was so hoping
that a rancor was coming out even though
i i was kind of like well there's no way
but the part of me still has moochie
moochie what is
[Music]
never made it they learned that these
guys were sent by the mayor maches and
they confront that mayor played by
robert rodriguez an ethorian with some
lovely whiskers i love the the gills
that he talks out of out of the side i
just love the productions
um he claims he would have no motive to
attack them and instead sends him to the
sanctuary cantina where gossip whip
informs them that jabba's hut twins
claimed jabba's empire and those huts
arrive with their litter finally someone
who announces their presence with a
litter uh and
that litter tommy deserves the gaffy
stick of honor this episode for not
caving under the weight i really didn't
think they were gonna
yes absolutely among these twins
menagerie is a massive wookie with black
fur this is black cursantin from the
2015 darth vader comics and dr aphra's
stories more on him in a bit and why
he's going to be super important uh
moving ahead but fenik tells boba that
he would need permission to kill the
hutts which is a bit of interesting lore
that we'll also dig into now the rest of
the episode is a flashback to
boba's time with the tuscans as he
trains with uh gaffy stick combat he
witnesses their suffering from a train
run by some pike spice runners spice of
course being the in-universe term for
drugs said george lucas just totally
ripped off from dune i was getting a lot
of dooney vibes this episode i loved it
this was some literal sand dunes and
some dune rip-offs
that's right i'm sorry you know when
that
vibes vibes when that train first
approached it sounded like a crate
dragon and i was like oh we're coming
back to the fact because we saw a great
dragon in the mandalorian season too and
then since then we've had dune so it's
just the fact that they made the
production design the crate dragon like
the sand worms of dune uh just another
little detail because before we didn't
know if the crate dragon
like burrowed through the sand like that
we just thought they like crawled we
weren't exactly certain of that uh but
now it's like oh why don't tattooing
it's just dune everything about it is
you know the the
the tuscans are basically just foremen
and we're not going to try to
differentiate it at all
um but um
but anyway boba tracks down that nicto
gang who raided the moisture farm last
episode they're now at a bar
bothering some familiar faces cammie and
fixer these were luke skywalker's old
buddies yes
biggs in the 1977 film so crazy that
they're back did you know
there's a great documentary i think it's
called 815 elm road that is about all of
the people who have small roles in star
wars and
one of the people one of the friends
uh was so like devastated that he was
deleted from that scene that he claims
he's the stormtrooper that says move
along when obi-wan kenobi like they
claims george lucas gave him that role
as a like
as a consolation prize for getting
deleted out of the movie it was like how
would anybody know he was deleted that's
what i don't understand
right that's all
but it's good to see them back along
with some people yes uh-huh yeah it was
it was crazy but it makes total sense
that they're there um now boba steals
these guys speeder bikes and then
teaches the tuscans how to ride and how
to like leap from bike to bike and then
they use these skills to hit the train
and tommy i just stopped writing notes
here because i was having so much fun
yeah this is like smuggler's run to me i
love a good train heist absolutely
delight
it's gorgeous and you know what high
body count yeah a lot of tuscans decide
this episode but
boba seems to be endearing himself to
the tuscans and also wiping them out
well we saw how many times any time that
train
blazes by
so many tuscans and banthas are dying
anyway so you gotta you know they're
they're and we don't know if they died
if they just fell from the thing because
it was rolled in the sand and yeah
dusted themselves back on they're just a
little sandy don't worry don't worry
they're still good they just went to a
sand farm up north
they're fine yep um but we see some
pikes uh and you know the pikes are one
of the spice runners of the star wars
universe and we see them in live action
they have these this interesting like
catfish kind of face yeah uh we've seen
it in the animated show them with their
masks but it's just kind of trippy to
see them like this now and these this
port race on a desert planet what are
they thinking
stranger in a strange land that's right
but boba gets his deal with them and
just kind of forces them to the terms
like you're gonna start paying for using
these routes and you're gonna stop
murdering us and he makes them walk to
anchor head that's how boba fett felt
when he was tripping some balls thanks
to a brain lizard
oh my god so this is the ultimate sign
of respect from the tuscans tommy and i
have been to quite a few hollywood
parties but with gerbils going into
different holes
eric i was going to say this scene
reminded me of a couple nights at
boardner's after an improv show where
you and i would sneak away into those uh
individual bathrooms and put lizards up
our nose
well at first your level two teacher
blows some coke in your face and then he
gets away that was that was down closer
that was his that was his basic
tentative improv was cocaine blown in
your face
things go up your nose then the gerbils
go in the different homes that's all
that was that was like and all these
different holes we're not saying which
but they go in it could be here and they
come out we're not richard gere here
we're not monsters exactly we're very no
animals are harmed but some had a great
time
these animals were harmed
party animals two animals
walk away with scars well so boba
tripped balls uh when he's uh looking
for this tree now this tree is
fascinating to me the sands of tattooing
don't normally have vegetation like this
but we were also reminded that oceans
once covered this planet much like boba
fett's homeworld of camino and i love
that montage that kind of linked the the
crashing waves of camino with the the
dunes of the dune sea uh just like a
fascinating elemental struggle and i
love how it's where morrison man what a
trooper and they threw him into this
weird ball pit of like tentacles and a
poltergeist tree yeah rape that was
happening yeah it was wild it was
horrifying
he i'll say this so far two episodes in
he is going for it like physically going
forward
like he's like this is my
time to shine this is what was supposed
to happen after the prequels and i'm not
giving this up like it's like maybe i'm
20 years older maybe i need more like
you know icy hot at the end of the day
but i am going to be very physical on
this show and i love it i think it's
great he's like what do you need me to
do all right let's do it throw me in
more slime
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're never gonna stop we're never
gonna stop well
he snaps off a branch we find out of
course this is where the tuscans get
their gaffy sticks and i love this i
love the world building with the tuscans
this episode i will never again call
them sand people they're tuscan raiders
i will not be my drunk uncle
oh we can't say sand people anymore no
no you can't next thing you're going to
say it's illegal to say happy life
nobody's
the episode ends with this campfire
dance where boba fett becomes a
full-fledged member of the tribe with
his own awesome gaffy stick that he had
to carve himself um now there's a lot to
talk about from this episode but because
this is wikileaks we gotta start with
that wookie black chrysanthemum who is
this gladiator why does it matter so
much that he's part of this world in
live action we'll talk about that but
first our merch partners at epic hero
shop have a new shirt in their latest
obsession series inspired by the book of
boba fett it comes in three colors i
think the military green is the most
character appropriate one but when you
grab a latest obsession shirt you will
get the added option to write a custom
shout out that will appear along the
bottom of these boba fett after shows
wilson says do you think that den jaren
will appear in the book of boba fett do
you think we'll see mando on this series
tommy i hope we do i don't think so
though i think we're getting i think
mando is being saved for season three
because that show is basically at a
reset now right like we have like he's
completed his task with grogu he has and
basically now it seems like it's moving
more towards some more mandalorian
discovery right like it's like he's
gonna have his own he has the dark saber
now what's gonna happen with that i i
trust me i want as much mango i want
mando on demand but i want him i got it
seven rings ariana grande but i think
that i think unfortunately we're gonna
be waiting yeah i i think you're right
uh forrest asks i just hope they make at
least one boba fett jet pack gag this
season yeah i was surprised that boba
didn't use his jet pack while he was
surrounded by the nightwind assassins in
episode one yeah he learned
maybe he's not comfortable using this
all the time he's not just gonna do the
jet pack like uh on command you know
he's gonna he's gonna save it for
special occasions it's like a bottle of
expensive champagne his jet pack he's
only gonna pop that back cork in case of
emergency and then travis says sand
people's children am i right well we're
not we're not calling them people travis
we don't say we don't use those words
travis we don't we can't call him that
anymore uh was it okay then
it's not okay now yeah but uh the
sentiment of what you said travis i also
don't agree with travis
thank you for buying it
thank you for buying we love you
we love you travis you're always invited
to our thanksgiving
no matter how drunk and inappropriate
you get or we get and we appreciate
everyone who has supported us with our
merch you can be one of them by checking
out our awesome merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
including all of our great options
including our awesome strange
entanglement shirt from spiderman no way
home but tommy let's dive into it what's
our first question
okay
what's that
you really said who the fed in a way
that i honestly heard the profanity
there your intonation was perfect i'm
getting better i'm getting better yeah
you have the spirit of the question in
mind okay well this wookie was
unmistakably black kursantin a wookie
bounty hunter and gladiator during the
galactic civil war who first appeared in
the 2015 darth vader comic story line
this was set between a new hope and the
empire strikes back when darth vader
went to jabba the hutt asking for two
trustee bounty hunters for an assignment
java gave vader boba fett and black
persianton so yes these two guys know
each other when they saw each other in
mos espo right there there was a
familiar exchange non-verbal but they
had some experiences together they were
part of the same group working for jabba
the hood so boba fett was sent in this
mission to track down luke skywalker who
had just blown up the death star
chrysanthemum was ordered to find an
agent of the emperor named silo iv who
ended up being killed by vader's torture
droid triple zero now after his contract
with vader ended blacker santon later
works for dr aphra in the 2016 dr aphra
stories dr aphra awesome character she
is essentially the indiana jones
scoundrel archaeologist of the star wars
universe and it's so exciting that now
we're kind of steering into that corner
of the universe because i'm telling you
we're going to love seeing this
character on screen yes i have high high
hopes
now through these stories we actually
learn about bk's origin she goes from
santee bk you know a couple different
nicknames he was an outcast to his
fellow wookies on kashyyyk and he ended
up as a captive of the slavers the
zhanti brothers who filled his knuckles
with metal to make him a better fighter
and turn him into the gladiator that
boba fett now calls him now later on
around the year of 10 bby now that would
be one year before the upcoming obi-wan
kenobi series is going to take place and
at this time bk ends up working as a
bounty hunter for jabba the hutt and at
uh one point he takes owen lars uncle
owen hostage and he fights obi-wan
kenobi himself and kenobi uses his
lightsaber to burn a scar into santy's
eye now we do not see that scar here in
the episode but to be fair it has been
about 20 years they have medical they
have back everyone's got a backed uh hot
tub yeah in their home as much as i make
a monkey i always think of wookies like
cats and hating to get wet or hating
water but uh even that's just my own
generalization they live like a chic
they got a beach ah i know this is just
listen i'm not normal but i think
i like to think of him in a nice back of
tank with his hair getting the blow out
you know afterwards he's blown yeah sure
yeah like teen wolf
wouldn't it be wonderful in the star
wars universe every wookiee actually
smells really good oh yeah and leia was
just being a jerk yeah but i think
wookie i like to think of wookies
smelling like fresh laundry i agree well
i think they smell like game flings you
know those like uh
or the powder the game powder you throw
in there
yeah it makes everything smell so good
you just want you want to feel good
hugging a wookie until they murder you
yeah
until they rip your arms off
now this little exchange between boba
and chrysanton where he calls him a
gladiator and he includes that dig about
the death pits of durr in a sleeping
transition guard a reference to a past
experience of these two characters we
haven't seen yet but it's just an imply
that these two had other things other
missions that they went on other
troubles that they fell into and he
calls bk the great gladiator just got
lucky by taking out a transition guard
while he was sleeping on the job it's
just a nice little dig and it means that
like we're gonna explore more of this
character and how they used to know each
other i just love that i love that there
was just more history between these two
mm-hmm but there's no way this would be
the last we'll see of chris santana of
course you don't build a huge wookie
costume and just
i don't know you don't scar a bunch of
five-year-olds whose real the only real
reference of rookie wookies is like a
beautifully quaffed chewbacca with like
the yeah version of chewbacca put
through a garbage disposal like scarred
up and like angry looking yeah or or the
wookie pelt that we saw last episode oh
god i thought this is the only wookie we
get in wikileaks and we'll keep going oh
oh god what a heartbreak but this cameo
tells us a lot about how the book of
office might bridge with other star wars
titles because he's one of many awesome
side characters introduced in recent
years of the star wars comics not not
every star wars fan reads these comics
but these are ones that are definitely
worth checking out and it's from the
original trilogy era everyone's
universally favorite era of star wars
and there's a very good chance that this
guy is going to show up in the obi-wan
kenobi series that's right on the fact
that he had that scuffle with kenobi
around the same time we know ewan
mcgregor is coming back uh with hayden
christensen as darth vader in hopefully
a few months we really hope may the
fourth could be the release date of that
obi-wan series i think well we'll be
here to cover it oh we will be here to
cover it uh but also chrysanthemum
showing up makes it suddenly in my mind
at least incredibly likely that we could
also meet dr aphra in live action
now i might be reaching here i often do
but a late trailer for the show showed a
brief shot of actress sophie thatcher
playing an unconfirmed role now but i
don't know it couldn't just be a
completely new character a different
character i might be reading too much
into it but according to the casting
rumors for that role the character was
given the alias of drash
and was described as cool self-assured a
defier of authority and in need of
refinement does that not sound like dr
aphra to you her character has like an
interesting skin thing going on there in
the trailer when she's on that bike i
don't know if that's gonna be dr aphra i
could be could be full of but i
want to ask you tommy do you think her
sentence cameo here is more meant to be
seen as a link to the past and the
upcoming obi-wan kenobi series perhaps
or a reach into the future of the book
of boba fett and characters like the
mandalorian grogu and ahsoka who could
now have characters like this indiana
jones figure in their midst i think it's
a bridge to the future i think i mean i
think the pa i think having the past
knowledge of the characters and then
having known each other is a nice way to
say like okay there is history here but
i think it's opening up a new
it's kind of like a spark of here's new
characters we can bring in not new
characters new odds live action
characters we're going to bring in from
more recent comics that are probably
like more in the in the memories of of
fans that take in all the content these
are these are these are characters they
probably care more about now you know
like they've read about recently and
have wanted to see on screen to go back
to your thing about dr efra in the
control i think we've seen enough movies
with characters that like before they
come out where they have code names that
are close enough like doctor drash
dr ash dr f i think that's close enough
of a code name i think you really are on
to something but in my opinion i think
that this could be
one even though it would be going
technically backwards i do think we're
going to see we're going to see bk in
the obi-wan kenobi show because it is
too much because you know they just have
such an iconic
encounter and then i also think that dr
aphra could be uh a potentially a good
character for this boba fett show you
know like i mean it does kind of have an
indiana jones adventurer's feel to it
already like it in the beginning of this
episode when they go into the mayor i
was like this feels so much like
original trilogy star wars right now
like walking into the like there's so
much practical effects going on around
or at least effects that are so good
they look practical even if they are
digital like they've really done a good
job of doing that now so
i guess my my roundabout long way of
saying is i think this is this is a uh
this is going to push us into the future
with these new tv shows i think this was
a moment that said this is not
necessarily mandalor this isn't all
going to necessarily tie back into
mandalorian original trilogy prequels
even though this show is so much
flashbacks i think this is like here
we're about to introduce a bunch of new
on-screen live action characters that
you've only known from animation or or
comics i'll say right now the show feels
like it's two different shows both of
which i'm very much digging yeah sure
you have the western influence dances
with wolves type storyline with mova
learning the the tuscan ways and
appreciating uh them as a culture um and
then you have what seems like this kind
of uh
mobster story right yeah
the then gunslinger learning how to
manage a group of criminals and having
to muscle out the other rival crime
bosses and i'm waiting to see the link
of those two stories uh i want i would
love if it's revealed that the reason
bobo wants to take over jabba's
operation is to give the tuscans more of
a say in the operations of this planet
oh obviously tuscans are the you know
they're often overlooked they're
considered the other but they have a
connection
to
uh to the sands of tatooine that
deserves to have some say in the power
broking of the of the planet so i'm
wondering if he is actually there as
their champion kind of like moses going
to pharaoh yeah look you know let my
people go and i i hope that that is
revealed at some point and he's able to
give tuscan some representation some
seats at the table um but now with dr
aphra we have this this uh
she's not even in the show i know we're
reaching right now but just like
bringing in we're excited we're allowed
to be excited
it gives the potential of an of an
indiana jones uh
vibe to it and uh i i'm curious to see
how they're able to weave it into those
two i mean we saw temple of doom temple
of doom kind of had those themes right
the plunderers versus uh the indigenous
peoples of the world
and things deserve to stay buried you
know um like so i could see how that
blends in but uh right now of these
story lines
i i want to know what boba's exact
motive is and i want to know what
finnick shan's exact motive is
when they're coming into conflict with
the hutts uh with the mayor of moscow
but i'm i'm i'm still plugged in i i
love what i'm seeing right now no no
gripes really yes
me even um well we have a couple more a
couple more questions that we want to
talk about but first thanks to
hellofresh for sponsoring this episode
the new year is a great time to focus on
what's most important to you whether
it's saving money by ordering less
takeout learning to cook or prioritizing
your wellness hellofresh is here to help
with endless options to make cooking at
home simple and enjoyable hellofresh is
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
delivers pre-portioned ingredients to
your door including farm fresh produce
that arrives within a week so you get
convenience without lowering quality
skip the trip to the grocery store avoid
wasting money on excess food i really
like that hellofresh pushes me to cook
and try new things i'm not normally
busting out spicy peruvian chicken or
sweet corn chowder but when i make those
recipes from hello fresh it tastes great
it boosts my cooking confidence so go to
hellofresh.com wookieleeks16
and use code
wookielinks16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts that's wookie with
two e's at the end of it hellofresh.com
wookiee leaks 16 and use code wookie
league 16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts we also want to thank
manscape for sponsoring this episode a
resolution you can actually keep is to
keep your downstairs looking nice and
clean in 2022 and our sponsors at
manscape are here to help join the four
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use code wookie for 20
off and free shipping it's the new year
new me with the golden leaders and below
the waist grooming this year take your
package to the next level with their
performance package 4.0 and brand new
ultra premium body wash the performance
package 4.0 has the signature lawnmower
4.0 with the advanced skin safe
technology to reduce those cuts in nics
and the new product that needs no
introduction
the ultra premium body wash from
manscaped it's a cologne infused with
aloe vera and sea salt to keep your skin
feeling clean nice and moisturized
whether your resolution is to work out
more to travel to new places be sure to
travel to manskate.com for our exclusive
offer get 20 off and free shipping with
code wookie manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use the code wookie it's new year no
pubes in 2022 with panscaped
something ironic about using a code
wookie getting
chopping my wookie pelt off of my uh
all right tommy what's our next question
eric what the fact
was the deeper significance of the
lizard and the tuscan creek yeah uh
fascinating bit of world building there
with that tree it's like kind of a there
some spiritual significance this is the
place where they get their gappy sticks
there's something some kind of um
significance to the wood of this tree uh
and i love this detail that uh tattooing
used to be covered in oceans and these
oceans have dried up and now we have
these vast sand dunes that makes uh i i
just love the sense of the history here
like i wonder if uh this tree is in some
kind of secret location that even the
tuscans don't know where it is the only
person who knows where it is is that
little lizard and that lizard is kind of
like a guide for them in the way that uh
ahsoka had the owl right yeah i had the
bird
so i'm wondering if this lizard could be
the same i'm not saying that tuscans
have like force abilities
but maybe the force is just kind of a an
energy i'm not using the term
midichlorians but it is an energy that
binds all of us and the tuscans have
their own interpretation right i'm not
saying that they're jedi and can use
these things but they have a version of
this life force that works for them and
it's embedded in the street as we know
in the jedi religion trees have a ton of
significance right uh there was a tree
uh underneath the jedi temple uh the
tree that luke's temple on achito was
inside of so i think to the tuscans this
is their version of that perhaps you
know i mean like if you're asking me and
i readily do buy into
you know or or watch this show with like
the force and all of the
and the light side of the dark side i'm
i'm okay with the fact that there is
like uh uh a species of blizzard that
can help bring people to a bring bring
uh yeah bring individuals to a to a a
tree that is uh a sacred location for
for a civilization like i'm fine with
that i buy that i like that especially
because it takes a little bit so
elemental you know cooker sugar to get
you there you know if you got to have
that
to get to giddy up and go you know well
that just greases the wheels that just
opens your mind so it makes your nostril
grow wider yeah that the lizard could be
like
we call it we call that a pre-workout
fan we call that pre-workout i mean this
spice plus the lizard the lizard doesn't
treat some of my favorite world building
i've ever seen in star wars it's so
weird but feels so real and grounded you
know it's it's just kind of flavor of
weird that i want to see more of in star
wars like this thing's going to crawl up
your nose
make you go on a crazy acid trip that
connects you to your home world
of uh with inverse elemental imagery of
uh sand but then big crashing waves of
water and then that is going to tell you
exactly where on the branch you have to
break none of us know where the fat this
tree is but you're gonna find it and
you're gonna come back and you're gonna
wake up and not realize where you've
been
it's so cool it's so it's so relatable
right guys
yeah we've all been there
um that whole sequence reminded me so
much of uh of luke's montage about what
the force is to ray in the last jedi
again one of my favorite sequences in
all of star wars where he sees it's like
kind of both of these things it's
crashing waves but also the calm puddle
it's the hunter animals but also the
mother porg feeding her children like
it's it felt like that kind of
macroscopic nature imagery uh discovery
uh channel that i just
fall so hard for
uh and like i i loved all of that so
much yeah me too me too i thought it was
amazing these shows can give us new
perspectives on what the force is uh
that never used the term midichlorian
look i don't want to be i don't want to
be the star wars fans like god damn it
you made it cells you made a biological
group why would you do that i i don't
really care that much that george lucas
did that i just prefer the flavor of
it's just yeah baby
connecting with love
a tree giving us a hug i'm the small
spoon in a tree that's revo hit that
piano
[Music]
so obviously we're here for this episode
the last question i want to ask you
tommy uh who would boba and finnick need
to seek permission to kill the hutts
and uh and side question did luke and
leia break this rule and return the jedi
luke by uh blowing up the yacht leia
strangling
yeah they're the captains of this crime
empire you haven't had a mission to kill
a captain who are they seeking
permission from i was trying to
sort like your art you are so much
better at timelines in the star wars
universe with movies and in cartoons and
animation and so so i was trying to like
frame like who is still around but it
seems like a greater question right like
it seems like an ancient question you
need to have permission to kill a hut it
seems to me like maybe even like the
huts are protected by something and i'm
wondering if that's more of a like a
sick thing like do the sith protect the
huts yeah i i'm not sure like i don't
know i feel like the huts are in a
separate um uh vertical uh power
structure from the sith and from
whatever remnants of the empire are
right
and there isn't really technically any
sith oh that's supposed to be a live
ring right like we know that the i mean
palpatine is just stating this he's from
he's surfing around the galaxy his soul
is just like
[Applause]
could it be uh
uh uh amelia clarke's character from uh
that's what's gonna say kira
knowing that maul is dead right now i
assume kira overtook the creation of
dawn right and she seems like a very
likely person who they could bring back
you know yeah clark's going to be on
disney plus and secret invasion
relationship with the disney plus team
right uh why would she not want to do
that that would be awesome that's yeah
so that was who i when i was putting the
timelines together i know she'd be older
now but it's like why wouldn't it be her
i mean like even if you had to recast
and cast like an older actress there's
so many great actors that could play
this role of this like hardened crime
lord now who like we know used to have a
sensitive heart and like you know was in
love with han solo and was in a
relationship with him and now it's just
like now you gotta go and kiss the ring
and say like can i kill right these sexy
hut twins yeah
if it's not the the family of the hutts
because i don't think
they wouldn't go to a family of us to be
like yeah these twins are the
cousins you can kill them off i don't
think the hutts would do that to each
other yeah the hutts are backstabbers
though maybe i guess yeah i just think
more likely it's implying that there's a
crime boss
across several planets above the hut yes
and i think kira is the likeliest that's
what that's that was my god so so
editors cut out that stupid sifting i
said first if we have time if not
[Laughter]
i'm the bad guy
i feel like we did a good job talking
about this episode me too i loved it so
much yes
and that's it for this episode of
wikileaks again easter egg breakdown
coming out tomorrow a lot of interesting
visual details that you missed this
episode wasn't just a big bag of sand
i'm telling you a lot of cool stuff we
got to talk about tommy and i of course
can be back next wednesday with a
reaction to chapter three of the book of
boba fett and don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at ea boss follow tommy at tommy
bechtold follow new rockstar subscribe
to wikileaks wherever you get your
podcasts we thank you so much for
watching and we have
okay
you